I have a 23-year-old stepson that's on
his second senior Year my husband pays
tuition rent utilities truck everything
for him when he does graduate he has
stated that he doesn't want to get a job
he doesn't want to be an adult doesn't
want to do anything except for basically
live off my husband so how do I try to
get my husband on board because you know
I've had the discussion many times and
his response is my money I can do
whatever I want that's one problem this
idea that it's all my money and so you
don't get a vote in what I do with my
money the other problem is it sounds
like he's been trying to buy his son's
love for a long time now and if he
doesn't have this anymore the
relationship will need some actual uh
repair yes that is true so that's what's
lying underneath all this that I can
smell a mile away but the conversation
he needs to have with his son is hey
I've been doing a really terrible job
raising you into the man that I want you
to be and that you need to be